welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and doctor strange in the
multiverse madness left some fans
wishing uh now you do plan to have a
multiverse on this multiverse tour right
hello
hello
yes i really hate that man
for a multiverse of madness the film is
set mostly across three or four
universes or planes limiting the more
multiversal exploits to one 39 second
montage where we're hardly able to make
out any of the surroundings well that is
what i'm here for to pause zoom and
enhance on the smallest details in these
movies to help you make sense of what
you saw and they give you the multiverse
you deserve in this video i will break
down the 27 universes that multiverse of
madness visits how each universe is
different the visual easter eggs in each
of these and what they tell us about
this broadening multiverse first the 616
universe christine palmer from the 838
baxter foundation confirmed that the mcu
we've been living in this whole time
where in this movie the battle of
camartage and the wounded war scenes
take place bears the numerical
designation of 616 which is also the
number of the core universe in the
marvel comics the first mcu easter egg
for 616 actually came all the way back
in thor the dark world among dr eric
selvig's scribbled notes on his
blackboard since then the number 616 has
appeared on scott lang's storage locker
sign an avengers end game mentioned by
quentin beck and spider-man far from
home a totally lucky guest since beck
was lying about his multiversal origins
and written on the tva filmstrip showing
loki's mcu light and for anyone who
argues that 616 was merely 838
christine's subjective label for an
alternate reality from hers i mean maybe
but the tva and he remains are universe
independent authorities who gave the mcu
the same numerical designation christine
did so i really think it's safer to say
that 616 is the number marvel studios
wants us to have for the mcu especially
since casting pru and interviews are now
referring to the mcu as 616. but this
movie actually opened in another setting
called the gap junction 838 christine
calls it the space between universes and
it might actually be the film version of
the nexus of all realities something
originally from man thing comics but
serves a similar function and some
actually thought the watcher occupied a
similar space in between universes and
what if but it's interesting how the gap
junction once had some architecture to
it stained glass structures with columns
and foot bridges so it wasn't just a
void accessed by portals it was an
intricately designed common area for
sorcerers and other multiversal
travelers to use and hide stuff in now
we should note that defender strange
must have come from some universe but
it's never identified and i like the
theory that he might have come from the
same rainy verse as tobey maguire peter
parker since we know that universe had a
doctor strange in it doctor strange
that's pretty good but it's taken
everyone i've really appreciated you
letting me be your guide through these
mythical fantastical worlds and while
you've escaped from one world let me
take you into another one the world of
dislight this video is brought to you by
dislight a stylish urban mythological
rpg from lilith games that is available
on google play and the apple store so
this light story takes place in a near
future where certain humans called
espers have gained superpowers and must
fight destructive miramon to protect
human civilization the superhero8
characters are based on real mythology
from chinese egyptian greek norse and
other mythologies fight as a
motorcycle-riding gender-swapped odin or
a monocled wolf-headed anubis dislight
has stylish visuals and smooth gameplay
and creates an immersive experience
using music and graphics really the
graphics and the character design for
this game are incredible the game is
designed for a vertical screen it lets
you automate battle so you can play
without hands perfect for when you want
some god on god battle action but also
need to finish cooking dinner or mowing
the lawn so check out the link in the
description to download this game and
use the code join dislight to get some
in-game rewards you'll be helping to
support the channel while also opening
yourself up to a super fun mobile gaming
experience now the third universe of
this movie the 838 universe this is the
advanced clean energy universe of the
illuminati pizza papa and the universe
of the wanda who gets possessed by the
scarlet witch now we made a ton of
videos breaking down this whole
alternate history with a fantastic four
mutants in humans everyone who's left
over really pissed off at this version
of wanda go check out any of those
videos then the incursion universe this
is the universe of sinister strange i
speculated this could be the universe
838 strange destroyed by dreamwalking
with the darkhold and sinister strange
was his host a variant who lost that war
we get glimpses of a few other universes
throughout the film showing one of many
realities with wanda and her sons baking
brownies and tucking in then wanda's
first dreamwalk when the scarlet witch
possesses another wanda during the movie
night now it's possible that each of
these are actually also the 838 universe
that wand eventually settles on but
wanda did see countless billies and
tommies in those red orbs so it's just
more likely that each of these are
different random ones that she tapped
into now the 838 memory bank showed
america's home realm the utopian
parallel at least that's what it's
called in comics here it's a floral
rivendell looking setting with
terrifying bees and then in the
post-credits scene we see our old friend
the dark dimension poem of clea niece of
dormammu and here she rules as sorcerer
supreme now the remaining new universes
flashed by in that 39 second multiverse
montage strange in america tumble out of
the 616 comatose past the living
tribunal a three-headed cosmic entity
the ultimate legal authority of the
marvel multiverse living tribunal
actually appears in loki as a severed
statue head in the void and mordo showed
the staff of the living tribunal in the
2016 film this divine justice oversees
all and various cultures clearly have
relationships with it next an unknown
universe with lights snaking in toward a
source looking at least similar to the
celestial world forge also evoking some
of the cerebral imagery from the x-men
films another unknown universe that
reminds me a bit of a cave of wonders in
aladdin that's just me though i see
disney everywhere then another unknown
universe made up of columns of ice
crystals now the next two universes use
some nature imagery a b universe with
bees joining around hexagonal hive walls
now think about it all of these are
depicting versions of midtown manhattan
so this is not inside of a beehive it's
a universe where society is run by bees
and it might actually be triggered by
the bee that freaked out america chavez
and caused her to open that portal that
took her moms then an ocean universe
maybe a reef or an aquarium then as they
break out of that one a few fish follow
them into a grindhouse universe which is
essentially just new york but with taxis
shouting out ride house releasing the
film restoration company of this movie's
editor bob marowski and long-time
collaborators of sam rainey i love how a
fish actually hits the windshield of
this taxi and it honks and you'll notice
they are in the same block as they were
when they fought gargantos they were
right by mancini's pizzeria and
interestingly a duplicate mancini's
pizzeria appears one block down but the
craziest universe is next a stark drone
universe it's a tube city populated by
the white tony stark drones from
spider-man far from home presumably this
is a universe where these drones became
sentient overthrew humans and rebuilt
society in their own image and i like
how we're seeing some links from
university universe b drones to these
technological drones next boom hell it's
a classic fire and brimstone realm
filled with bones and skulls and
skeletons we see a bone lamppost
dripping fire a rib cage building both
of which are being scaled by skeletons
as if these guys are trying to keep off
the ground remember moon knight
explained how the various afterlifes of
the mcu the ancestral plane and black
panther the duwatt egyptian underworld
of moon knight are all part of the same
thing just different incarnations based
off of the beliefs of each person so the
way that the damned to the duot would
play flora's lava with the sand might be
why these skeletons are doing the same
like if they touch the ground they may
fall apart into these heaps and piles of
bones next universe dinosaurs maybe
universe where dinosaurs were never
wiped out in that apocalyptic event in
ancient times next an animated cartoon
universe with some looney tune style
marching band music underneath now this
is not the same animation style as we
saw in what if they pass a jonas and
james sign so again this is the same
midtown manhattan block next a plane
crash universe it's a city block with a
large propeller plane crashed in the
middle of it kicking up some rubble and
some live wires sparking on the right
side of the frame i suggested before
that this could be new york if the
valkyrie plane and the first cap film
hit its antenna target that wouldn't
explain the green flames i honestly
don't know what to make of this one next
the cube universe that you've seen in
trailers strange in america beginning to
transform to cubes some of those cubes
actually being stone this reminds me a
lot of the abstract thought sequence and
pixar's inside out where those
characters broke down into simpler art
mediums just like these guys go from
cubic form to a sloshing paint universe
which is one of the 73 americas said she
had visited before and right before they
leave it there seems to be a car or
something made of paint on the far right
of the frame there then next a 1930s
universe 1930s new york with model t
cars a brooklyn bridge and a blimp all
under this grainy film reel that some
suggest it could be the universe's
spider-man noir earth 90214 but this
isn't the same aesthetic it's not
monochromatic black and white it's
desaturated sepia it's actually closer
to the 1930s new york cap and bucky grew
up in which seems like a minor
distinction but really the aesthetics of
spider-man noir are everything to that
character then this interesting pyramid
universe with a stonehenge configuration
now remember thor the dark world
suggested that stonehenge was built by
the ancients to point to the coordinates
of the convergence now the eternals
movie suggested that the eternals might
have been helping ancient humans with
this kind of stuff moon knight had
several kang shout outs suggesting the
history of vararama tut using the sphinx
as his time machine might be accurate
and then again the x-men days of future
past post-credits scene showed
apocalypse building the pyramids in 838
charles xavier quoted himself from that
movie so who knows i just like the idea
that this could be the universe of the
original gods that the eternals were
based on the gods from olympus what
their version of earth would look like a
mix of ancient stone structures and
advanced technology next there's this
dark cyberpunk universe that looks like
the world of blade runner a little bit
then this sanitized futuristic universe
with much brighter light 90 degree
angles but still some new york icons
like the hell's kitchen water tower on
the far right and then finally a fiery
realm covered in lava rivers a match cut
contrast to the 838 that follows it
having a waterfall in place of the lava
fall of this one now some have compared
this to mustafar from star wars but the
mcu does have the realm of muspelheim
home of surtur this also just might be
hell hell with one l just a more
actively volcanic part of the realm that
odin banished hella too where loki
actually thought he was when he woke up
in the void this realm returns the final
act the setting that america chavez
initially tries to banish wanda too
therefore it might be where the souls
the damned come from in a realm that we
revisit soon so there you have it 27
universes visited and dr strange the
multiverse of madness and in most of
them the food is free and thanks again
to dislike for sponsoring this video
download the game today from the link in
the video's description and use the code
join dislight for some great in-game
rewards follow me on instagram and
twitter at eavos following rockstars and
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you